very happy to be welcoming million
thousand all this evening and the
talking sponsor co-sponsored with the
Department of Sociology million that
home is a sociologist and the ski in
Santa has research fellow at this off of
my today at the echo of a la segunda
blue dome she received her doctorate in
theology from the Silva because he
thought he sang and has also spent a
number of years in American University's
Institute of French studies NYU where I
first met her and her prime area a area
of interest in specialization is the
sociological study of socialization
processes and more specifically the
study of cases of individual
transformation through socialization
whether in total conversion to vary my
new changes for research examines how
people change what makes them changed
and what they change in to muriels first
welcoming of her dissertation was a
sociological training anorexia published
under the title do no NOS seek you have
and more recently her work has tended to
focus more on elites and particularly on
elites in the educational system
including the festival 12 and wounding
gun and the debates around these elite
institutions in French society in
academia and debates about how leave
education is changing particular so
please join me in welcoming bring your
hands down the hall for this talk on
state ability rigidus elite education in
france today thanks a lot to you heading
into the mental process of is very kind
invitation thanks to me also for health
and also to enough that appear to not
choose to be in France instead and I've
also made it possible so the toke as
advertised will be in English I've done
before but not that many times so please
forgive me in advance for individuals or
unclarity to keep track of time I may
have to read my notes are so it sorry
for the inconvenience but I don't
it's really too boring just stop me and
I a stick up without so I will begin not
quite traditionally with a lighter tone
and since we are in Columbia we do so by
making a quick reference to a TV show
that happens to take place here in
season 3 of gossip girl one of the
character the overachiever player is all
worked up because she has been invited
to join a secret society called laptop
editor that she describes like this
they're modeled after the particle in
friends secret salons for the image of
academic institutions finally something
exclusive to strive for something worthy
of all my pent-up energy and attention
this is a very specific and maybe a very
American vision of the French in school
system the schedule almost like a dinner
party where in networking secrecy where
selectivity is a question of social
capital window and not so much of
cultural capital work if that sounds
familiar it may have more to do with the
American Greek world of fraternities and
sororities then with a little education
in France anticipation in France even in
French movies is on the country and
French novel sometimes is on the counter
as much more Stern and academic journals
defined by idea of gravitas of an
institution that has to build a spacing
ability this frame modulus views is a
title of a group published in nineteen
eighty nine by the sociologist Calhoun
do why built this talk about it of and
rounded sorry it's more like it because
it's been a very infinite influential
book historically speaking but also
because it is still a very useful book
due in part to the fact that since then
very few books for articles have been
devoted to the frontier each education
system we have been on a matter to be
call of the state mobility except from
for some historical studies and lots of
statistics are showing user to use
basically the same thing I need the
enduring social selectivity of
recruitment of any schooling are to
reach will go back in a few minutes but
the boy from that not much and for
example no validity for ethnographic
study of the elite education
institutions on the other hand there has
been lots of standards in sociology or
education in France unfailing students
underprivileged students drop out and
almost nothing on good students
successful students get a lead
indication so until recently staining
ability as to like a wonderful
analysis one of the clangor there was
one small problem the fact that the book
was published that had said in 1999
based on beta ranging from the 60s to
the activity 80s and so clearly even if
it's our theoretical insights may well
be still decisive the question of the
question of is descriptive accuracy and
parents fortunately but independently
imitation has recently gained a renewed
interest in France coming both from the
media and politicians and from scholars
that sociology it has definitely become
a hot topic in the last five to ten
years where they studied that you can
basically make the same statement for
the US as witness as witnessed by the
cluster of studies and books recently
published on illegal recruitment and
education and culminating issue in the
recruited by a shame scam my own
research I would on which I will offer
it story of which I will only speak a
bit today it's part of its wicked
interest but with a specificity most
most if not all of my French colleagues
and been working on the very recent and
very political if you if you want
experiments that have that has
added to the old school system of any
schooling in the last 10 yrs and that I
would present you in the second part of
my talk on the country I thought it was
important to work on the same
traditional and dominant edit education
institutions that had been studied by
Roger in the 80s and on which we still
know so little as I said so for two and
a half years I ought to the day-to-day
life of several French preparatory
classes that will explain what it is to
those who have never gone in humidity
made interviews with students and
teachers and attended classes exams
evaluation sessions and more informal
moment it is this research and the ones
that are being made within a small
circle of sociologists working on the
subject in France today that i will use
tonight to revisit the description and
analysis of bordeaux state mobility to
examine whether state the same and what
has change for the last 20 years first
maybe a few words of description of what
constitutes an education in friend i
won't discuss as i should return elite
and its implications let me just say has
become a standard way of referring to
the most selective
citrus park the country's higher
education another language notes i'm
going to use here the translation of the
english version of them ablaze Nita so
it will speak of preparatory classes or
prep classes for the plastic aqua which
is so so I think that maybe prep schools
would be a more accurately and I will
speak of prosecco for conflict oil
images better enough as you probably
know if you come to this conference and
maybe you don't fine with me are the
largest part of the French elite is not
trained as elsewhere in universities
that the bronzing club which are
distinct our institutions of higher
education and to prepare for the
competitive examination examinations
allowing access to these in coil most
students follow two or three your
courses at preparatory classes although
there are more less equivalent to
undergraduate university studies on this
promoter classes are located in the pc
in high school so that it's basically a
student from 18 to 20 as far as ancient
culture so if i were to make Roman and
love spreadsheet comparisons to begin
with and we say that
ron zook oh this is easy the French
equivalent in the universities in the US
and had prep classes and this is much
more difficult are close to the lesser
of any boarding school plus with
negative events placement may be here or
something anyway that seems to me quite
quite for more a specific bronze eco
mainly fall into two categories into the
ring school and our business book to
this we should add the two quite
specific and iterative and Bobby Cox
calls that are skillful enough and the
various economic effect Americans
economic area Vanessa we train scholar
and researchers in science and
Humanities and livingsocial tastes like
chemicals and it being Venice so these
are the schools there are consecutively
different prep classes to prepare for
each type of consequat scientific prep
classes with a large focus on hard
sciences to where students for the
examination of engineering school and
awareness economic classes with a focus
on mathematics history economics and
in general knowledge prepare for
business school and literary classes
with a focus on humanities mainly for
best students only for the three burnett
are more recently for some business for
so to sum up prep classes are the two or
three years following high school and
baccalaureate where when a small portion
of the student population Iran is around
five percent of their age group prepare
for the book one that is to say the
highly competitive examinations
following access to the bonds occur
these will park brake students
anonymously according to a
one-dimensional scale of marriage they
are written and if one succeed in the
oral exams but for example that low
interviews are former grades either in
high school or in prep classes do not
count in the pool pool it's what you
managed to prove anonymously on the
d-day that count the only criteria of
their fourth are supposedly academic
ones what are not criteria or character
personality or to biographical SS while
sebacean in extracurricular activities
of the highest
sports skills the presence in the family
of the na'vi night and even better
generals one all these are supposed to
have nothing to do not only with the
poor poor and the excess contigo but
with the very idea of the academic
scholarly scholastic meritocracy and if
there were Wars to say that and with
them on which a system that is based so
on this some things have changed but
we'll get to that later so when it's
specific to French elite higher
education is not so much should probably
call in themselves I said it's quite
close to our editing abilities but the
duality of the system is too full nature
first preparatory news then score Newton
a few seconds prep classes are supposed
to be and farm to a loter as to a large
extent a very aesthetic time all work
and no play outstanding of someone
gloomy and even disciplinary art
institution as i will show presently on
the contrary 19 one week on candy sweets
much
the schedule is much less that work
there's a great article on them on the
various roles are played by by careful
in different schools how you don't go
out and drink at the same way
engineering schools or business schools
for example and what is faced at the
schools so it's not the academic
asceticism on the one hand the prep
classes and school and campus life on
the other and one can you can argue that
it is precisely this destruction and
succession of tension and letting off
steam which constitute a science the
sufficiency of the French system when
compared for example to its American
counterpart whether broken beer are more
mixed and maybe in different proportions
with with the discussion me let me then
give you an idea of life in these
institutions with an emphasis on preps
for which I feel are more specific and
also happen to be much subject so
staying ability emphasizes that
asceticism and duress in breck classes
are a way to manifest social superiority
these are the those who are deemed not
to be double to end your sexual life
puta barata notion
job gains that of negative riffles
between against Eva I deep wrinkles and
not showing that one man masters nature
report his or her own nature when it
ended obvious to the researcher in that
tension as it is known concentration on
work is still a very strong and visible
a component of prep classes life as a
consequence it is self-evident but for
lots of French sociologist but these
classes are a fine example of a total
institution almost in the most valiant
Aryan a fan starving government had in
mind winning corner turn so it's examine
quickly why automatic sent out there
round first pro classes inmates are
closely selected are during the mission
procedures on both the brain and their
attitudes toward school they have to be
straight a students very invested in
school work but also very compliant our
students and from I gather there's drama
the observation of a mission of
procedures and committees that name at
the beginning of the two years I am I am
also of the various formal or informal
to Ramona's of omission which are aimed
at taking a poop on on students and
Barbara is government again
as conditioning them into working into
devoting all their life for two years to
the aesthetic aesthetic word world of
knowledge for example there are numerous
speeches added by the headmaster of the
high school should also be Hannah
Cerreta Roberto glasses and this is very
rare in transit I mean not the kids love
here with friends a headmaster and
doesn't do many speeches so numerous
speeches which I learned so much pep
talks that as simply speak pressure
talks you basically tell them down the
student to put every moment of their
life at the surface of the group who
even tell them not to falling off or not
to fall into passion because that would
be detrimental to academic concentration
also the situation at the beginning of
the professor's is that of instructional
managers are once again traditional
procurement and using the frame of the
free from government so once again the
traditional component of life in total
institutions previous academic ranks and
positions are no longer valid every
student has two billion from scratch
with new methods euros new difficulties
the process is very close to the one
identified me any boarding schools in
America by James can yeah whether
schools
aims at showing that to students sorry
although not in a demeaning way but they
must be taught from the beginning and
that what came before position of
preparation does not matter throughout
the practice this institutional breath
is maintained and even strengthened in
my research I nip at this point
government and use the analysis that
foucault a group of disciplinary
institutions and the way these
institutions assert their power through
three perforating for gold three subtle
but very efficient instruments civilians
section and examination for example
whereas total institutions exert their
power by imaginary originated icing
department the well you see what I mean
the human material they work on the
Prescotts do so by individualizing and
even over individualizing the evaluation
and the definitions of every student's
qualities and weaknesses let me just
insist on one aspect that is fundamental
to
life the importance of time and of the
feeling of urgency that is imposed
during these years in this aesthetic
lifestyle time the passing of it the
rhythm of it the relationship with play
a major role as already suggested by
beau jo's notion of urgency in the off
state mobility issues that Burton see is
a way to prepare students for power let
me quote state mobility on this by
joining a student the students entire
life into a competition placed under the
sign of urgency a race against the clock
preparatory classes like sports in other
traditions create a simulated equivalent
of the real struggles of ordinary life
within the universe of school would you
go on by saying that without leading to
explicitly state underlying principles
the institution does indicate a
deep-seated dispositions and namely the
propensity and the capacity to make an
intensive use of time that will later
give an advantage user from displayed in
the struggles of professional life this
urgency is still very much a crucial
aspect of prep classes life moving in
the fabric of everyday life as I started
I observed the numerous ways in which
professors what they say what they do
manage to constantly accelerate time and
even fast hope for accelerate time and
initiate this feeling of urgency for
example when I asked one teacher if I
could present my research three students
before sitting in class women for all
yer he said do that on the day when I
have them during four hours because I
can't use these five minutes on a two
hour session and in the interviews with
students I found numerous signs of their
incorporation of such a reason the
result of a specific temporal
socialization of having news to film
time and ten passing in a certain and
virgins when time becomes also the
matter of all things in prep classes of
individuals abilities or difficulties of
hierarchies between students past
students are quite skillful what I also
discovered what that the attitude that
children's managed to adapt towards
urgency can be referred to their social
position are the feeling of mastering
time and still being able to believe to
breathe at high speed is
more present in student from upper
classes families this our last remark
brings us to you another and fundamental
feature of elite education conference
today its enduring social selectivity so
1989 are the urine state nobility was
published was by no coincidence the bike
center new of the French Revolution
Buddhist aim was to demonstrate that
privileged and mobility still existed
albeit in a different form than during
the occupation another state when it
created protocol and created a new kind
of nobility justified both in its own
eyes and interview of those who didn't
belong to it and were nonetheless ready
to acknowledge of its legitimacy on this
state nobility builds on two previous
works by module investment reproduction
and the inheritance which aim at proving
that the dispositions are defining
scholarly excellence are in fact those
detained by the other classes unlike
these two previous books stating ability
is centered normal school in general but
on academic elite are proposing another
and guess your
preferences and 10 it shows that the
students from other classes are over
represented in the phillies academic
institution one the social basis of
their academic excellence is never
acknowledged as such where they're
headed institution so it is still true
today between 1989 and today the number
of students in prep schools and worldly
court has considerably grown from 1.2
million in 1980 22 month 3 million in
the our 2009 so they are both students
there are also more professors more prep
classes outside Paris that has also been
a booming the number of in the number of
economic prep classes but in spite of
all this um the ratio of students in
these classes to their university filter
gods so first year students are
surprisingly say exactly the same around
seven percent so it's still the very
selective system but is it's the more
puppy that's a little one I already said
it it's not in the figures now
this top 7% if you will come even more
than before even more than they did in
states in the Middle East I'm from same
place in the social space of software
classes what you would say that is from
other classes feminine and only are two
to three percent of working class
children entered quantico social
segregation is at its best in the top
brown single one in a thousand of a
generation gain entry to the top four
ronica pretty technique as you see in a
Vanessa and eighty percent of these
students come from other classes
feminine you can compare that to the
University were only the third of the
students come from the same type of
classes and to the fact that this at the
glasses are like fifteen percent of the
French active proclamation so fifteen
percent of the projected population
gives way to eighty percent of these
stop people and since the second half of
the 20th century things have only gotten
worse if we take once again the
magnifying glass of the top four scores
in the 50s certain percent of the
students were from working-class
background in the nineteen
tease they were down to nine percent so
the thrust of state mobility and more
generally in Buddhist work and school
social reproduction and elitism if it is
if I may say so even more true today a
last very important point made by state
mobility lies in the definition of a
field of higher education and the field
of bronzing hope I won't enter any
theoretical discussion of their
evolution of North notions or in a film
but let me just say this prep schools in
bronze eagle do not exist in a social
vacuum they do exist in relation to each
other and to other institutions they
exist in the field of social forces that
make each of them clothes or way friend
or foe of others within the field there
are conflicts and struggles for power
and legitimacy between the institutions
when they fulfill like all fields are
the field of higher education
instruction by opposition let's consider
two of this briefly that you are these
opposition's first and these are
opposition to try blooms implementing
first between a great store and a minor
door to killing position positions when
Buddha insists on and what is still are
prevalent today is your position between
on the one hand prep classes and bronze
eagle attended by students of ad- class
and
families and on the other hand the
University which has welcomed together
with middle-class students the new
students of working-class background
hits the massification of the nineteen
seventies inside the field of granting
of itself a similar opposition that
exists between the most prestigious
schools when the students come mostly
from Kornbluth west and will probably
end up there too and the minors course
not naturally well known and often
located outside Paris where both the
students and their social destiny are
thats a middle-class one to translate
the vertical drop eternity me choosing
another opposition distinguishes between
schools that are clear through economic
or political power such as lena of asha
see where students come from families
with even more money than have diplomas
to the schools that are closer to the
academic internet intellectual or
artistic power such as Uranus with
students who who conversely come from
families where diplomas are relatively
higher and family incomes typically
children's of teachers and professors
sentinels
is also still valid as early as within
the practice ism cells are students in
literary web prep classes for their NS
or much more often children's children
of teachers and learn and professors
whereas in class is preparing for
business course they are coming
relatively more from professional
families and this is our children
is it ok so far my mind understandable
you would have set on being right the
structural perspective given by the
notion of the field of higher education
is a good starting point to inquire into
what has changed since 1989 I first
entered the second part of my talk and
you will notice that I did something
that I was not supposed to do that is
due the first quarter note whether some
change and then second row of what
that's actually changing when I was at
school to us totally forbidden to use
this kind of gross at my sergeant the
two positions are just mentioned not
good for anything just mentioned there
but this to your position in the field
still define the structure of the field
of montival of higher education but some
changes took place the greatest one of
them has been brought by international
organization which I will not happen it
was not mentioned in the nineteen
eighty-nine addition of state ability by
poor dude again very soon greatest
question in interviews in the media
about the book and it is now a question
extensively studied by some of these
disciples and followers
internationalisation they suggest that
capital besides cultural economic and
social capital that are the treatments
modern reporters in capital as new
capital s emerged and defines new
dominant position positions it is called
international capital the field of
higher education is never indeed an
internationalized field as witnessed by
international policies for universities
international rankings or the other
present idea of a globalized market for
higher education the situation then
stream legitimized a new kind of
international cultural capital made up
ability and taste for a geographic
mobility a kind of upper-class way of
dealing with natural diversity etc in
the field of higher education in France
such a promotion of international
mobility was surprisingly around the
1980s a strategy used by second-ranked
bronze eagle small business holes in
their struggle with a rate of home decor
promoted mobility and
internationalization because it could
not compete on academic grounds come and
study here won't burden you with glasses
and we'll have lots of our trips the
room today on the contrary I listened
with any other an international problem
exponent process of the most prestigious
and academically read over our schools
for example are very high requirements
in five languages study or internship
the ground
vital part of the areola
internationalization of faculty
cross-listed diplomats with foreign
institutions classes taught in English
sometimes in German near the Afghan
border etc the students from ponticar
also largely using Erasmus program
designed to bring internationalization
to the university systems still more
than forty percent of students entering
the program come from Quantico this
growing importance of international
capital has definitely had an effect on
the field of higher education it has
benefited mostly to the first
participants in this
internationalization so what's up once
again our business course but when it's
interesting to note in the fact that it
may have resulted in a reinforcement of
academic requirements and orientation
for these schools to participate in this
international field of higher education
business schools for example in friend
must have in the faculty not so much
people coming from the interpreter go to
infopreneur real world best scholars
much more easy ever to add paper papers
published in leaving peer-reviewed
international journals that is often
American pianist I don't have time to
develop this
of this but this trend of
internationalization has had some real
effects on day-to-day life of the
students in prep schools first in the
recruitment of prep classes and even in
the comprar of business on the court the
French traditional exam with no personal
disclosure of any kind banasthali
forbidden and this supplemented with
much more biographical and personal
evaluation for example within speaking
of business prep classes so economic
protectors of new Gotham and for example
with an important interview quote on
Twitter personality personality
interview which used to be not so long
ago an exam in general knowledge and
very challenging scholastica also
students in these classes on that
supposed to learn how to write and save
up what they think which is once again
very far from the norm of competitive
exams in France and if you look at
student life also I observed that in
these tough economic classes the real
popular kids were always students who
had spent lots of time exide friends and
especially students who had spent part
of their academic career the United
States than Whitaker really the top of
them
and even more deeply are they were
precisely described as I did as popular
popular which is a new way of framing
the social juvenile hierarchies in
friends and a new way to challenge the
monopoly of academic criteria in this
hot rocket in prep classes but we never
used to be only used by sociologists
referring to working class and that it
means something or feels different and
unique American offense opportune that's
not this Americanization is not a
problem if it's 70 for an organization
but this strength clearly up in effect
on students and some families more than
others and it is far from being a way to
end reproduction how banditos you have
make welcome and stand it's all the more
the case when such a transformation in
the field of all the code may go both
eco and strengthen the transformation
occurring at large within the french
other classes and their capitals in
would your theory economic and cultural
metals are what define position of power
the most powerful situations aggregating
both type of capitals economic and
cultural but Buddha and his team showed
clearly that in order to succeed at
school it was better to be relatively
well endowed with cultural capital
whoever has economic capital was
relatively not so useful Maps the
boundaries hypothesis has recently been
made of a growing importance importance
of economic capital relatively to
cultural capital in that matter to quote
from one scholar in France the
intellectual fractions of the middle
classes have traditionally been
advantaged by the full moon and strongly
scholastic meritocratic procedures of
access to the same bronzer code they are
or whether challenge today because
feminist with higher incomes are able
successfully to transform an economic
capital into cultural capital through
residential and school choice private
tuition and private preparations for the
best and
nations and I would add that last but
not least the new international capital
we will be a very expensive one to
require but by gum trees start of road
for example if this is correct this
would be a really important change in
the field of higher education and
friends this bill has never been totally
totally meritocratic one but at least it
was not solely and not even primarily
dominated by money and if working class
children statistically never had their
chances at least our children of
kindergarten teachers and more chances
to succeed in it when children of
afternoons but not highly educated
businesses so time will tell if this is
going to change and that would be
something that would be a really
important change this problem and more
generally our social reproduction and
not been ignored by consequat and the
media although it has not been casted
the sociological terms I just use the
second important chant changes in state
mobility lies indeed in a new
preoccupation and a new set of practices
for bathing prep classes than consequat
I am referring
the debate about diversity in any
dedication we have to lose yet under
this name of programs or experiments
have been launched in order to shape the
elite reproduction system and to broaden
broken access the two elite education
for underrepresented groups the debate
has been framed both in terms of social
justice and in terms of social
efficiency and even economic
productivity vitamins are come from
business managers asking for renewal and
but we will see that it has also been
for the schools involved the rice and
clever fair thing to do in a specific
political context and specific state of
the field of Rome people the first of
these problems is one launched by your
school the top administrative and
business school in two thousand it
created a special admission track for
the students of seven high school
located in economically disadvantaged
three years that with a view to
diversify and democratizing the school's
admission process I'm putting here a
very useful text by then yesterday again
which has the advantage of being
available in English and in the drama a
French politics culture and society
instead of having to take the
competitive exam impose and all other
applicants those students who are asked
to write papers and defend them in front
of a jury made up of teachers and
administrators of there
high school then the best candidates
were invited for an interview at celtic
oneself those who received an admission
offer at the end of the day were also
provided with financial aid as well with
us with a specific kind of tutoring to
other kinds of programs were launched
since the top business school rd effect
established in 2002 30 Veronica why not
me experiments based on individual
tutoring and work sessions organized by
students from vehicle and proposed to
straight straight A's underprivileged
students from working fast Damon and
fondling the top high school well known
for its prep classes gonna step on gas
created in 2006 the first prep schools
prep spoke to prep schools class
podiatric was into Somalia men is to say
an extra year of high school designed to
prepare traitors and recruited students
once again to press for with a focus on
teaching them methods cultural ease and
implicit knowledge that are natural to
other classes are students the architect
of this project as random thought quote
you for yourself he knows what
up to following these initiatives other
province have been created since from
two thousand and five others the state
itself has become an actor in the
process through various legal test
shuffle identity shows with manifest
your to death and also various of
residential addresses a first
presidential arc in 2006 then quiznos
sacristy in 2007 called for the
incorporation of thirty percent of
that in students on financial
aid whose families are below certain
income in prep classes when they see
import of these problems are first the
jury is still out on the actual benefit
for the students that have gone as
fruits and it's quite early and it is
often been said are nonetheless that
although these problems can be effective
in limiting the limiting sorry processes
of self-exclusion due to institutional
cultural of economic factors their
impact sims are limited studies on
students who entered through such
channels showing the entering effect of
previous social origins our pro classes
and only God hero are not a scholastic
melting pot selected but we're all
differences disappear once the student
body is
constituted the value of one's diploma
even that elite diploma rest heavily on
one's previous social resources and
capitals moreover the debate is still
raging on the adequacy of such
individual solutions to a collective and
structural problem for example the
leading piece by born of F in a recent
special issue of photos journal
regulation of Joseon devoted to these
experiments is called new programs so
works it insist on the fact that
universities were the majority of
working class students complete or not
their higher education they are not
benefit far from it from the same amount
of money efforts a little more attention
these very limited programs are yet
nevertheless such a social probation is
shaping the debate but also shipping the
field of rhonda cole the sociologist
onion from dalton has shown that with
that kind of probation prep classes and
convict oil have achieved the devil go
first they are managed to religion it
there Thank that function which has
which was tainted by social and letters
for reproduction stignem but they also
had managed to be recognized as actors
in the political field for example shows
were really managed to set the agenda
and given the political agenda on this
and has clearly benefited from
we shall define present was considered
following all this for cabinet position
as Secretary of Education more generally
there is active position of schools like
self 20s deck in the field of Gandhi
current has suddenly been changed for
the better and sectors of social ethics
I stuck here on this question but God if
you want to know more and read French i
will highly recommend a special issue
that the sociology journal and the
editor of oxidative olive oil and
devoted to this question of diversity
through african-american alconbury c and
d converse with God that these
experiments with presented stand this
five minutes okay five more minutes ten
more minutes
another kind of people and bring home
the current have been much more discreet
and had aroused much less attention
young women money per semester worked
with voodoo on state ability work back
with not explicitly credited that a
co-writer comic book undercover and
recently revisited state the ability of
self by by saying that one very
important feature of the field of kanji
koi general had been overlooked
completely in this book I do concur and
you know in a pocket book that I've
written on admission procedures in
crevices and body on their gender bias I
know that one very important analysis by
boo johnson attention beautiful analysis
of her therefore one so when it's very
important analysis on categories of
perception category long-term officer on
is bad judgment on a female class made
by a male profession but that is this
dimension is not even mentioned in the
book but if we live today a prep schools
and consequat gender can no longer be
overlooked the most obvious
transformation that took place during
the last 50 years is he increase in the
number of women it was not as early that
has high and increase as in the
university but as far as Brooklyn
home decor Ombudsman women take a long
way prep classes and configure for avoid
school and have a visual sensor which
there are no longer there was a reddish
thirty-one percent of women in 1975 and
there now forty-three percent close to
50 it's not fitting but generally
qualities are nonetheless still
programmed there are many more women in
literary that prep classes were hard
science our prep classes and engineering
from the club are still very masc ones
but we use our business for classes of
almost fifty fifty percent although
there in that attempt even for the cool
ones to drive growth and young women to
science things may be very slow to
change our when you hear as I did your
method for roughly of scientific prep
classes what math professors have to say
that a woman's brain and logic all the
villages and you don't want to know I
didn't have to say similarly during the
ritualized collective review our
students are by teachers at the end of
each term for second data that I
observed categories of descriptions of
excellent female students were
systematically in this scientific prep
class ism where scientists were
systematic
on the serious and hardworking side one
side even when she's got a beautiful
handwriting the Correa's excellent many
students were rented inventive ax t or
vision as far as scientific ethnicities
were concerned I have described
important changes in the field of French
higher education its student body in the
debates that is social function and
these changes reshape the institution
himself moving up to my confusion
regarding in our prep classes of which I
said that they could under many criteria
be seen a sultan institution there had
been a virgin hole and structural the
legitimization of estoppel rather
totalitarian character both state
policies and teachers discourses for
example offended to display a new kind
of this institution sorry no more
pressing no longer bloom so word on the
academics read is that the whole system
has softened as been modified what is
it's not what he used to be and it's a
good thing is it true that sometimes a
good thing with that it's not when you
disagree well clearly practices have
changed the practices used to be
regulated by a sort of like it or limit
our policy and drop out in the first few
weeks were the move those who come to it
whether teeth will stay but it is no
longer the Norman teachers are
subversive being slowly the
Oh through they supposed to keep their
students and to bring them to the
competitive examination at the end of
the two-year period they are constantly
are being reminded by the superior who
are in the media of a higher clothes
cost side are supported by the state for
their students compared with University
students and teachers feel that they are
under review and much more out that they
are much more accountable than they used
to me in a word there's a person and
they feel compelled to curb the
potential symbolic violence of
institution which they do in more ways
than one well why they are still using
on the other hand the Arsenal of control
provided by the total institution
because they had to make the students
work this explains why I had my fill
notes are so many customers used by
professors to speak of their work in
interviews and in the informal
observation these are some errands
aggregate the traditional total and the
new human character of institution give
you a few example I use stop translating
and I use sometimes that it was not easy
club and don't know
young frankly I use sometimes if I room
fist and sometimes the velvet go when i
connect it's very nicely prep school is
a prison but a fourth stars1 you playing
by the carrot and then you play with a
stick but the thing is it doesn't mean
institution is no longer powerful or has
lost its hold on our students it's just
a different kind of green it asserts its
fun work through the more compassionate
but also much more intrusive and
expensive domination for example it
helps students with their way of life
their health it advises them to do some
support to let off steam to sleep a
certain number of hours to go to the
movies not to fall into fashion as we
saw but to enjoy each other's company
the Daleks are not only their work but
that state of mind their psychological
even during content Latin it elevates
their motion a more conventional
institution is also much more intrude
intrusive our institution which can
extend its power on students to the
maximum this is why more than a total
whore disciplinary institution I commit
perforating new kind and envelope in
institutions the city of lubaantun maybe
a blanketing institution with
translation combat powerful but not
oppressive
and powerful because it's not present
too and this conclusion verifi i would
say that any reputation of staying the
ability today should post on the title
itself and on the expression come by the
common current reporter a thing ability
is in Silver State the village asics gel
missed out on some self evident for a
French year of left leg my generation
and before but this evidence made it
into fade as a presence the importance
of the French state in the field of
higher education may decline of course
it is a state who created or
restructured the most prestigious on the
current after the French Revolution and
prep classes and configured were at
first designed to serve state needs and
are still in the majority public
national institutions state funding
everything but the rise of business
goals which offer the most point private
the dynamic or private and public it
comes in but the rise of business call
of the dynamic of the field itself which
sins in a way more loosely connected
with state guidelines than before as we
saw with the social experiment where the
state the state came after the schools
if you remember
well and especially the pressure of the
so-called international market for
education may well be the sign of the
decline of the state's principal the
same principle of legitimization of his
nobility so the question has been asked
by many sociologists start and then in
the last 12 years what has become what
becomes of state mobility when symbolic
capital is granted outward by other
institutions or by other states this in
here and long thank you for you question
it's about can we know which school you
know you can
exactly is it the number i was not i
will give you as many information as you
need to get a picture and she's living
is I choose not to go to the most
selective and prestigious prep school
but I choose not to study on prep
schools were entering home decor is on
the the case were very huge cute so it's
some good tongue a good love the casa a
good absolutely Paris prep school I
talking about a working-class and
middle-class yellow glass and I
understand that those places have
different access to the contractor I
right on the fat how to do how do you
define those classes in five sure this
is i mean i think that the young the
best enter here with the statistical so
just to give you an idea for working
plans I this is like
yeah the children of warriors and also
on for you which are low-skilled jobs
and this is this announced to I let's
say 50 a bit more than 50 and 55 percent
of the active population so when I say
after class it's it's more like a
pathetic a permanent fastest and that
would be like for French in French
Catherine focus wanted in Westphalia and
this is like sixteen percent of the
infected population so mental crisis
would be like in between one of the
changes you mentioned was the
internationalization of the guns I good
but in your examples you talk mostly
about internationalizing those students
either in their preparation or in their
studies one of the big advantages that I
think many universities have and that is
especially true for the big universities
in the United States is inner
internationalization in number sense
that is people from other countries
studying in these institutions and
confronting their ideas and cultures
with those of American students what to
what extent is that
the case involves a call and I suppose
there's a difference between the private
and the public but can you give us some
idea of the percentages of foreign
students in in the different contexts if
you want to be in the exact percentage I
didn't look it up because I'm not sure I
very point exactly but but yeah it's
true it has been part of the
internationalisation and while watching
it after maybe you're fun Betty that it
has been said that okay I give you it
has i've been done in in cm sporty
technique as well yeah yeah i wrote a
number 44 shells for just hear what it
is but i'm sure i've got the number for
short school and i think i could find
with got here now Hans a spot for the
UNSF and pretty thick me and not for
sure my pants it was that largely like
the dice for shampoo and for business
schools I mean if you look at business
school websites they advertise largely
are the percentage of our foreign
students well then that must be a bit
different because it's really forming
public servants for the French
government
oh yes it does although European
students can under some attend classes
and via rented position at the end of it
and this difference the athena is also
different because you've got in our
schools outside with friends I mean
abroad valeria so I and they have bad
also it's a kind of a a model
international
when I gather my answer both high spot
and Aunt Em today a graduate student
administered on a study in schools in
the late 19th century not advantage in
Germany Britain and Russia primarily so
I'm here basically just to get as much
information about the system as I can
really don't know much at all about it
but I find very interesting that the
French had made such an effort to create
what is you know to create a meritocracy
for example in Britain you know the kid
beat the idea of character which was
almost a code word for certain
aristocratic traits was very much part
of the admissions you know process and
also has been not like books on this
column what this character memory other
uses right and I don't I can't help but
to think that these recent efforts at
trying to diversify the student bodies
have
is also somewhat going against the idea
of meritocracy and I wonder if you if
you you know thirty percent of
this of the student body perhaps being
not have some mollified as other you
know other portion population if that's
definitely to to the nation in the llama
fourth or if it's actually a you know a
lot actually have a beneficial effect
well there have been lots of debates on
this inference on the fact that has been
is it the meritocratic thing to do for
the armored or credit in to do a very
different positions on this I the thing
is if you if you look for example at
your school are one of the abyss course
you have the name there was a monitoring
of it
other students to see if they were doing
equally well and the other kittens and
require other aha but this is and that
the result for that yeah basically they
were they had some witnesses but they
were doing equally well the thing is in
school in the schools in France or not
as highly haha and has dimmable to other
system as a prep blessing so basically
everybody goes from one room to the
other so this where this question was
and was asked in this very young flat
for it couldn't be answered because yet
they were doing equal of well but the
question is when what I'm going to
answer on what I think of this I think
that well on the young do I think it's
detrimental I think these are good
experiments and Gouda and good thing to
do just to try to shake things up but i
do on here i think that maybe it's a way
also of evading the problem which is
much more structural and
elastic so I would be on here on this I
would be a more urgent than I'm i'm
usually and my finger and say that in a
way entering this question has is less
important than seeing the you know the
tree hiding the forest oh I am somewhat
surprised just follow up with them so
they're somewhat surprised what you say
that students are doing you know
pleasantly surprised
if the statistics shows this through
students were doing as well I i went to
attend the brunette states military
academy we had certain affirmative
action policies or quota policies in
place in order to create because we
haven't totally the Commission to create
a you know a diverse officer corps that
represents the enlisted soldiers of the
army and we succeeded that but this
students from certain artists from
certain minority groups clearly don't
performs a lot so simple contrasting
back it just you know if you don't be
fresh so if I'm not selling to you again
my beautiful trim and everybody's that
worked out well well good answers to
your impression of the thing is and
whispered and on the humor bitches
yes I just want to ask you if you
thought that
current changes
high school precious than work going to
an effect on time students that that go
next year or advances himself human how
would I briefly mentioned of the
economic preferences Brigham Young said
yeah I think it does i mean i think that
the young the fact that via the web
requisite slats in it i guess it's okay
a chain for example the economic classes
it's not the same path straight A
student the same idea of the poop or
student that they're trying to recruit
and this is going to change something I
think because you've got many cases of
student that were academically brilliant
but for not being like to be on for
example were not involved in
associations or what not involved in
extracurricular activities which is to
be a thing that was not even talked
about or even the existence
in the universe of F and preferences and
only things extracurricular activities
the parties for example they are the
higher the food chain is a student that
is that do well academically but also go
to the parties that are now almost
institutionalizing the economic
progresses and you've got to manage to
dance until four in the morning and then
to succeed in your math Adam next
morning the same morning to and and of
course of this song and this has changed
things I had the level of juvenal far
Rockies but also having ability in the
kind of student when these glasses are
preparing the nectar it schools are
going to recruit and actually the thing
is this economic professor some other
one that are I've mushrooms the more
friends over the last ten to
twenty years and also or now the most
selected prep school so we are if you
look at the young the social origins of
different craft lack of students in
different prep classes
the job is one one type of this economic
practices and that is it's like they are
sixty-five percent i think this class is
about children's classes and it's the
highest I words above regarding the
question that was previously asked on
whether students from different social
class saying how cannot very surprised
you say they they do because it's true
that I
for the requirements large nut yeah
for us but I think what interesting is
whether the employment rates are the
same the thing is at the employment race
and get the types of jobs that they gave
after are still are they are they have
been the statistical studies that have
shown that it's better than if they
wouldn't have go through this but it's
still not as good as the one that are
from hiring social origins and that
one's through Quantico so it's a kind of
you makes less image you but this means
don't really like the double press both
gonza God is kind of osa antigua like if
only we only considered this as being
becomes occurred because only the best
year has no they're not because these
schools provide the best education I
know my threaten I my brother went to
the SEC for example he told me that the
classrooms we are going and give you to
feel like he was actually learning
something by probably will have a good
job and a good solid me just because you
have this yeah well there's this is in a
way are the biggest is this pure energy
of the system because what schools like
music or for example testing you to be
shown for I should think what they do is
to thank you very hard one these colors
/ sizing is colossal sizing I don't even
remember what it what it is in French
well they take students and they are
transformed them from from their very
lukewarm attitude to future businessmen
so they have to break every what they
feel that they have to break every
tendency to to continue seeing as in an
academic way maybe they try to serve a
DPS the reading they trying to turn like
intellectual from prep classes into
something different and I was referring
to another four we found when we force
our institution on that so in a way they
don't want that they don't aim at being
intellectually satisfying it's not what
they do and it's very different from
other kind of spoke with this one
american university is columbia
conspicuous among them teachers are
forced to do research and researchers
are forced to teach and public and there
was a cartoon some years ago outside it
will appear placement office OD Christ
on the cross and the caption read he did
not publish what was very apt I thought
the friendship reps do it differently
the cns gives the researcher a chance to
concentrate and research and there is no
teaching ability it makes the difference
and at least in cash it was in da da da
da it has been 30 years producing Magnus
opus whereas here is what you done for
us lately and of course riches is ground
down ground out by the reams in totally
unpublishable editions and published in
journals ago
well I don't want to I you know to
sending you at the French situation but
yes there is a second husband it's a
very small part of the actinium and I'm
happy to be part of this weather right
3226 positions within a specific
disappointment so and the thing is I'll
never serve in French you say
traditional Finnish so publish or perish
is less become like a human language yep
cool my way to anistar with you bet
every day so and the thing is it's that
plus the fact that we have to do it in
English which is not our language and
I've articles in English and to have
them accepted not only by our journal in
French which is ok but why international
tennis to share birkin British is
looking to weather mirjam also and when
you do in statistical mathematics
English is not problem
when you're doing that for examples of
gelatin and the graphic and you've got
to prison translate our social
connotations it's not funny I think of
John Paul sharp who didn't teach you to
you distributable yeah anyways teacher
at some point yeah we had lots of there
is a lots of philosophers up I mean hi
Gil you don't and true intellectual
philosophers were teachers in our class
tabasco on in Twista very interesting
position this is another clip but also
because now intellectual in France tend
to be more and more defined by our Shore
school understand human back embed and
not so much at the even imagine a half
ago so it's a very different kind of
that is cooking
I i worked in france for a number of
years and and something that amazing
even though i understand there with the
country before was the shared admiration
for intellectualism and in fact that i
had never known that there was
profession of being a antenna until I
was in France and some people were
presented that way to the public but I
also i also found that working in
industry or in commerce that the people
who were graduates of the gauntlet
called who were automatically piloted
there perishing into the top ranked top
levels of those companies tended to be
to demonstrate something that you talked
about earlier the fact that they were
intellectual bet I maneuver their
animals so they can they endured the
glass plate behind me they come out on
top but they were also the fairly
socially inept and that most of these
people were 40 techniques so their idea
of running an enterprise was more
military than anything else but it led I
thought to a an almost impenetrable wall
between these people who were admirable
and for the intellectual capacity
and the people that they were trying to
lead who who certainly didn't share that
and didn't believe this and that
was another thing that amazed me with
was that the graduates themselves had a
certain arrogance that I could
understand having gone through what they
had but means it's like the sex but but
the other French people didn't seem to
mind that they seemed to share the
admiration in the same to the same
extent that the the graduates at
arrogance because the whole country had
this admiration for the intellectual
capacity per stream and and i found that
admirable in a way but i didn't find it
the most efficient way of doing business
then maybe you would be a four-piece
today because this may have changed and
that the thing is that's what i said on
the relationship between economic and
cultural capital
maybe something really deep is changing
here India in that distribution but also
the legitimacy and a differential
legitimacy of these capitals and so this
and then well write this for example if
you take a Christmas a cuisine is the
first one of the young of the right-wing
presence of being first Republic not to
come from consequat and and also maybe
you've been you know that is Don sama
let's say cultural capital bashing of
over the years part-time life and this
is quite new and is quite systematic
also Kinnear said well this may be the
same trend of different powers or they
do thomas lee attributed to all these
different
suppose is clearly the president of
economic capital against cultural
capital intimated in a way are the
trouble that these capsules are idea
that what it has that there is a trouble
for a specific kind of capital that
you're interesting interested in
promoting because it's sure your stand
up against the other kinds of cattle
we've already asked your question and
question action on the programs
and friendship what is it so i
programmed a team water and last moon
has expired also that owners and money
was being
one
now and I think 11 capsule was I am
super gay people
future
two
26 people we have an impact into the
institution is a closet as i see i
conclude that Mason 7 that is good at
chess with having to program but I can
do
attention that's that that would be when
I think as far as the specific target I
leave under with underprivileged
students is concerned I think that it
has effects but more on the field of
country girl on the public debate maybe
on a political level movies fact that
it's true that I am quite once again I'm
not so sure this is a solution but it
while saying that you can say that when
you see that yours after yours the
statistics are the same software
doctrine is the same I think that it's
only natural to want to experiment new
things to try to shake things up a bit
but the thing is in it can have the
thing is everything is done now it's
very complicated because it could have a
positive impact on self-confidence I for
students even if it's one student but
then in his niece a group of friends
endo that they could if they work and
then go to this or that
and better studies ethnographic studies
of the students are English for example
the prep classes to prep classes show
that it can also have very good
detrimental effects on the table
dimensions and because those who don't
succeed even in these systems are so
they think that it was to get targeted
for them and they did not succeed it's
hidden even more violence than through
the usual sister and the thing is also
it's done there are lots of fun idea of
a betrayal betrayal betrayal of one
class of one's family is using this kind
of system is it a way how to become
maybe some categories of forever hoosick
so
quite quite a lot of research actually
show that the effects even up let's say
psychology motivation well being enough
are clearly at best a movement
anyway
cool
which basically say you are saying a lot
of athlete about principle and only one
political but the robot to all system
vacation sure the thing is the prep
classes are not responsible for social
reproduction because when they have
witnessed many many admission committee
but they take the best students really
they don't look for Ottawa in Odessa
they just make the best students will be
more suitable a sweet ago triple star
attitude and this amounts to eighty
percent of so the thing is the problem
is clearly elsewhere it's built through
half the whole our school system from
econ weatherman because one of my first
actually whether the first year of a
continent kindergarten and well thing is
there were already a difference coming
from the social origins of extremes kids
so and it's of course it's a cumulative
process so idea 18 and within the
process of entering just about wat
everything is already done before is
true that it's not the responsibility of
the purposes for comical
but it's also true that this is of
course an argument try not to shake it
and not responsible for it tonight very
true i mean nobody enters castigado on
secret by sleeping and going to parties
hi work anyway this is the best students
yes in this country any graduate from
American high school but the only thing
that keep him out of a college or
university I think with organic brain
damage and I'm not altogether sure about
that how many popularly having friends
DN a-- approximately what percentage of
holders of the back shoulder in France
do i do university ave
I know that what they're trying to do is
have eighty percent of students take the
back LOL yeah yeah and there which
percentage yeah I may have this I didn't
know it was going to be at your buttocks
night so i got this favor so if in my
lap oh you look it up with you it's
well now everything I wouldn't uh I will
yes I don't be 90 portion 19 and I know
ah yeah yeah something like that between
ten and twenty eight well know it a
header 2016 or 10 or 20 do not oh sorry
you mean succeed in the University of
hope you can get to know we have how
many you are in the universe you're
gonna go natural yeah yeah I would say
ah well find this right oh yes because
five percent go to home
ha ha prep classes but this five percent
are five percent of a generation of the
core cohort and then this five percent
you've got many we don't go while many
we've got some we don't go until the
better right when ya know I think that I
got somewhere percentage of a French
young high school but he'll arrange
students who go to university she may
use that what you are asking I will look
it up but it's much more than five
classes but it's
engine okay I'm very much is getting
yeah and what what are the sources of
the cooter characters laying plans or
what what why what factors that are
determining that the employment rates
are that you mention it community our
skin haha the source of good record I
mean surnames or origin store oh yeah
its specific social already have more
specifically are the deployments that
parents have achieved this is a cultural
capital that the proxy for cultural
capital is the parents diploma in
modesty ya understand maybe understand
what
finally when they put the employers are
selecting people they are not seeing a
proxy right there to bring a new people
and they are said that they are in fact
premium rates between people that are
going to six children so what are those
who when you're seeing the serving of
the people or how they looking at the
deployment of the people once again and
so they are looking at if you come from
a poor nicole said this road to
employment well high school employment
jobs I think he's mentioning about the
different employment rates we were
between different social classes
from different social classes like
surnames address okay good thanks I'm
sorry I beginning to get late feel
exactly well yeah this there are lots of
studies as the graphic studies on that
the recruitment by being in the job
recruitment in the job market the fact
that I your attitude the way you speak
and your network or so because it's all
on the cultural capital it's also go to
become social capital that is who you
know and and all this is embodied in
your very persona the way you present
yourself to other and service children
were not chosen by our prospective
employer
I think I was getting tired i dunno yeah
I can think 12 more ok if you fight for
it yeah
thanks to you watched our contest
musician
and save the world led to what
got you into this
it's not a small question whether yeah
well as Chen mentioned what interested
me in interested me in this weather was
to study how an institution transform
for not transforms or not a person and
even at a very powerful institution and
this one what effect does happen people
that are going through it so I've got a
case study if you will was burnt my
homework is a case study of how this
kind of finger of an institution and to
what extent this constitution transform
treatments danger pure and crispy four
hours
but
and then did you have a question of what
I do and what was nothing would you
stake ability not when one who brings to
the entry
there is another product
move
oops career like four
well I wish you did that it makes him a
very different subject but it's also
quite kind of close because uh I used to
say that I was interested in that you've
asceticism in a way and even if it's not
the same and in anorexia that all
athleticism is like an individual and
not induced by an institution compared
with the very young ascetic institution
aesthetic making a set of young a
setting forcing institution that is just
about walk but in a way in most cases
I'm looking it's a very specific kind of
use that has or is aesthetic as to be
warriors are you saying you find out
higher enter you think you will find a
higher incidence of anorexia among right
class yeah if not really when a part of
my work and I know I was on the fact
that it was anorexic girls came from
abdominal classes and other classes and
it's striking in a way because the same
percentage as 16 let's say a bit more
than sixty percent
anorexic girls come from at the middle
classes and advertises family and so
which are usually the ones you sent me
yeah same percentage so that's why in a
way are you will find more but also
Vickers this aesthetic dispositions in
the anorexic case can easily meet the
ascetic institution that are the God
wanna do the kind of connection that can
have you here washing my let's get
anorexic or they just get Arabic I don't
know what year when they go through the
class no exclusive identity that's not a
pool of anorexia written in English
publishing in English in the draw a
british journal of sociology which is
called the fifth times
and the change and I've written myself